i did bury my son's foreskin in my
backyard
really yeah and then it
rained
and we went outside and
it was kind of like floating on
i thought you were gonna say a dick tree
grew
and now we pick the dicks like pears
yeah they're fresh yeah
wait it came up like a zombie kind of
guy
yeah and then it for some reason it just
kept attacking other boys penises
it was
i we had this brit you know we have a
breast like jews do yeah
and uh and the the moil which is the
name for the guy that does the
circumcision he like he
put the my son's foreskin in an envelope
and handed it to me
and i looked at one of those check
envelopes so you could tell pretty much
it had like it had like the plastic
thing where the address should go
and so if i held it this way the
foreskin would like drop to the
like
it's so hard to pick the right card to
include with horses i know yeah thinking
but it was like i remember he handed it
to me and i was like like what am i
you
what do you want me to do with this and
yeah and he was like in this very he was
like you go you bury it
you say a prayer
and then it's done
which is like if i wasn't jewish that
would have been so anti
anti-slavery now we're okay with a very
typical jewish voice okay good good um i
want to do it yeah it's funny but you
know what are you gonna do i got it i
cut it off i put it in the envelope you
bury it yeah
but so i was like yeah
we're breaking down walls here so i took
it so i i took it and i and at the time
where i was living at the time i didn't
have a yard really just had like this
area of like like pebbles
and so i just kind of like kicked a few
pebbles out of the way
and like opened the envelope and was
like
i fell out and then i just kind of
kicked a few oh my god rocks off for it
and then i went inside and uh and then
like two days later it was a horrible
rainstorm and we came out and the
foreskin was like front and center
like what was that all about staring at
us yeah you tried to get rid of me
you shoulda you should have dried it
you should have dried it yeah you should
have dried yeah except that would have
been weird if like
someone walked into our house and it was
like hanging outside like what are you
doing oh we're just drawing four skin
you